Major new developments involving
former President Donald J. Trump.
Trump saying today
he expects to be arrested on Tuesday
and is calling for protests
He made the announcement today
on his social media post,
lashing out at the Manhattan
District Attorney's Office,
which has invited him
to testify before a grand jury
The arrest
would be part of their investigation
into alleged
hush money payments
to Stormy
Daniels during the 2016 election.
Again, if there is an arrest,
that's according to Trump.
Trump
also called for protests
over his pending arrest
to, quote, take our nation back.
This development comes as sources
tell CNN
that law enforcement
agencies in New York
are also now preparing
for the possible indictment of Trump.
CNN's Polo
Sandoval is outside
the Manhattan Criminal Courthouse for us.
And we can also begin with CNN's
senior crime and justice
reporter Caitlin Palazzo.
Caitlin, to you first in Washington.
What more do we know about this
possible arrest that the former president
is announcing on his social media post?
Well, Fred, when
and what is going to be charged
if it does?
If it is charged,
we don't have the answer to that yet,
and neither does Donald Trump
at this point in time.
His team, through a
spokesman, has made very clear
that there has been no notification
made to him
or his lawyers
that he is going to be indicted
or when that indictment
is going to happen.
However, Trump is very aware
of the politics of this and the bluster
and the bully pulpit that he has.
And so he is agitating for his team
to try and get his base riled up.
He did say in that post about protests
asking his supporters
to protest in some way.
He also is sending a message
to the New York
district attorney, Alvin Bragg.
And if we step back for a second, Fred,
the reason that there is this expectation
of Donald Trump
that he will be indicted here
in New York by the D.A.
is that
the long investigation
into the Trump Organization
and payments
made to Stormy Daniels
for hushing her about an alleged affair
she says that she had
with the former president,
those investigation
that is nearing the end.
We know that
because there was an invitation
to Trump himself
to come in to the grand jury and testify
He declined to do that.
We do understand
through our reporting this morning
that another witness is expected
to testify
before the grand jury on Monday.
So it does not appear
they've returned an indictment
at this point
that would cause Trump to come in
and and turn himself over that quickly.
However, it does appear
we are in the end stage of this,
and the grand jury
will be reviewing the evidence
and at some point
very likely voting on whether the former
president of the United States
should be indicted.
Fred, All right. Thanks so much, Caitlin.
Now let's go to Polo Sandoval
outside the Manhattan courthouse.
Polo, what can you tell us
about any preparations by law enforcement
agencies that might be taking place,
especially after the former
president will make that
announcement via post
Yeah, Fred, still with many questions
about the
when they certainly don't
want any question about the
how they would handle all of this.
And that's why
you have these conversations
that, according to our colleague
John Miller, are ongoing
among local, state
and federal law enforcement officials
that are in close
contact with also officials
at the Manhattan
district attorney's office.
The crux of the conversations,
they're exactly how to navigate
this scenario
with a potential indictment
and then also the choreography
that would come involved
with potential charges being filed
against the former president.
And that's
why these conversations
have been happening.
And then it's post
January 6th World to better believe
that court has security
is one of the big parts
of the conversations
that are happening right now
with law enforcement officials
privy to the discussions, saying
that they are preparing
for potential demonstrations
for pro-Trump demonstrators
to come together here in lower Manhattan
and the potential
of any possible clashing
with anti-Trump demonstrators.
And so this is certainly something
that is top of mind behind the scenes
as they prepare for the coming days.
And certainly also the U.S.
Secret Service
having their separate discussions
about how it would work
in terms
of getting the former
president to Manhattan getting process,
getting potentially booked here
when and if that indictment is announced.
And this is a routine, Fred,
that we should
mention is certainly
not unusual for the New York state
court system
here, but it's
certainly because of the complexities
that come with this.
It certainly would rise
to the level of being unprecedented
as we prepare for the coming days, Fred.
Right.
And that involving a former president.
Polo Sandoval,
Caitlin Polanco,
thanks so much, will check back with you
throughout the afternoon.
Let's talk more about this right now
with Elliot Williams.
He is a former federal prosecutor
and a CNN legal analyst.
Elliot, good to see you.
So what do you make of
the former president who would say this
via his social media post?
Do you believe that
he has any particular intel
that says he
might be arrested on Tuesday?
Well, let's look at the good, the bad
and the ugly of it. Right, Fred?
What the truth is, he might have received
a heads up from law enforcement
that he had a surrender date
as of whatever
it was,
20 Wednesday,
and that he had to turn himself
into law enforcement by then
or face an arrest right now.
That's if the
if this were all working normally
and accurately,
of course,
that would be how prosecutors
and law enforcement, New York would have.
Or he's
just making it up based on things
that he read in the newspaper.
And there's no way to know
either of those things.
But to be clear,
all those points, there's
nothing novel about a defendant
getting a call
from law enforcement
prior to being asked
to turn himself or herself in. Hmm. Okay.
So then on that first point, then,
when you say,
you know, there may be a surrender date
and then it might say you face arrest,
you know, if you if you don't comply.
So what is usually the gap between that?
If he did receive a surrender date,
notice of a Tuesday
if he didn't comply right away,
then would that mean a matter
of hours within the same days
within within a day?
I mean, I'm sorry about that.
It's within a day.
It would be your surrender dates Tuesday.
We can arrest you,
starting with,
you know, maybe a list of time, 5 p.m.
at 5:01 p.m., you're subject arrest.
Now, they may reach out to your attorney
or they may try to get you to come in.
But no,
you are subject
to being arrested
by the NYPD cops or whomever else.
As soon as that surrender
moment or date passes, Okay.
So any potential indictment or arrest
would stem
from the probe of Trump's alleged
hush money
payment to former adult
film star Stormy Daniels.
Are we talking about a misdemeanor
or felony?
It could be. It could be either.
You know, under New York state law,
there is a misdemeanor
admitted to practice in New York.
There's a misdemeanor for
business record violations.
He could be charged with that if, in
fact, those business records
lying or
misrepresenting our
business records
was in furtherance of committing a crime,
which here might be campaign
finance or campaign violations.
Then it bumps up to a felony
with a four year maximum prison sentence.
But it's just hard to know.
And it's the Kaitlan Collins
point earlier in the segment.
We don't really know
other than what sort of leaked out
what the former president
might be being investigated
for right now.
All right.
So I'm going to have to ask you,
you know,
put into context a lot of this,
because the indictment
and you know,
or potential indictment
and potential arrest
of a former president
for criminal charges is unprecedented.
But how people understand
kind of the journey here,
because it's been a case,
you know, a very long time.
It was the beginning of his presidency
during the campaign
when a lot of this came to light.
So what does this tell you about now?
Potentially
there might be an arrest
or surrender date.
What does that tell you about the case?
Potentially and. Yeah,
yeah, absolutely.
The events of this case
stretch back six or seven years.
It's not like someone commits a crime.
Yesterday,
and then you go and arrest them.
So No. One. It's a very long saga.
If it ends up in an arrest
or a prosecution over
what might be a misdemeanor
that happened six or seven years ago.
Now, certainly there
is a great deal
of public interest in the matter,
but it is a relatively older matter
But again, it's significant.
It's also logistically complicated,
I think, to arrest
and perhaps the United States,
the Secret Service everywhere.
all of this creates a bit of a mass
both legally and practically.
Oh, my gosh.
Then that brings me
to which Secret Service assist
in his surrendering.
What they should they would receive.
Again, we've ever seen this before,
but they would receive
notification from The New Yorker,
whether it's the state troopers
that, you know, the NYPD about,
know we intend to have this person
surrender himself
or get arrested on this day.
And law enforcement
agencies talk to each other
all the time about such things.
Now, again,
you don't ever really see
the circumstance
of a former president being arrested,
but that's how it would work
if it were working correctly.